(déflagrations au loin)
- C'est ici que se joue
actuellement la bataille
de Marioupol, dans llelelelexe
sidérurgique et métallurgique
Azovstal, construit en plein ère
soviétique dans les années 30 et
qui est devenu, avec le temps,
l'une des pluseseseses aciéries
au monde. On décrit l'endroit
comme une ville dans la ville.
DOMINIQUE AREL, Chaire en études
ukrainiennes Université d'Ottawa
- Ça été construit aussi
pour soutenir même une guerre
nucléaire. Alors, il y a
une ville comme souterraine.
C'est là q d d d derniers
bataillons ukrainiens, qui
seraient peut-être jusqu'à
2000 soldats, sont concentrés.
- Changement de stratégie pour
Vladimir Poutine qui avait prévu
un assaut. Ses troupes vont
plutôt assiéger le secteur.
Il invite les militaires
ukrainiens à déposer les armes
et leur promet la vie sauve.
PIERRE JOLICOEUR, professeur,
Collège militaire royal, Canada
- La stratégie de
Vladimir Poutine d'aujourd'hui,
c'est de passer pour humain
et un homme raisonnable.
On sait que ça fait partie
des principales accusations
à l'encontre de la Russie
qu'il y a très peu de respect
des vies ukrainiennes.
- Le président ukrainien,
qui accueillait aujourd'hui
les premiers ministres e
et danois à Kiev, l'admet :
"Les forces russes contrôlent
déjà une grande partie
de Marioupol."
"La situation est difficile.
Nous croyons qu'elle n'a pas
changé depuis hier. Comme vous
le savez, plusieurs milliersded,
des militaires et des civils,
surtout des femmes
et des enfants."
À des milliers de kilomètres
de là, Washington annonce
une nouvelle ronde d'aide :
un demi-milliard de dollars
américains en argent
et du matériel militaire
supplémentaire.
Cette enveloppe de 800 millions
de dollars américains inclut
des livraisons supplémentaires
de dizaines de pièces
d'artillerie lourde,
144 000 obus et des munitions.
Difficile encore de savoir
combien de temps les forces
ukrainiennes tiendront
le coup à Marioupol.
- Dans t-l-l-l-l-l-l-là,
c'est la grande inconnue,
jusqu'à quel point...
quelles sont les réserves
en termes de nourriture ets s s?
- Et pendant que les militaires
ukrainiens tiennent tête
à l'armée de Vladimir Poutine
dans la deuxième ville
en importance du Donbass,
le bilan humain, lui, augmente.
Des images satellites
montreraient une fosse
commune récemment creusée.
La société qui a prise les
images estime qu'on y verrait
environ 200 nouvelles tombes.
Ici Pasquale Harrison-Julien,
Radio-Canada, Montréa